- Hey everyone, what's going on?
What's good?
Welcome to Market Takes.
I know you could have
been anywhere in the world
but you are here with me
and I just wanna let you
know I appreciate you.
I am Dion Rabouin, host of Market Takes
and reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
Listen, there's a lot going
on right now in the world.
We are trying to break
down the state of things.
What you need to watch
for this upcoming week.
We're gonna talk about jobs,
'cause of course it is Jobs Report Week,
the credit crunch right now
that a lot of folks are worried
about in the banking sphere,
and the possible recession.
Things that people are looking out for
that are gonna tell us how close
or how likely a recession is.
We're gonna get some hard data on that.
We're not just gonna talk,
we're really gonna look into the data.
So we're gonna dive into all of that.
Before we get into this week's
non-farm payrolls report,
which is of course the big
kahuna of the report this week.
We are also gonna talk about,
first, the state of business.
We are gonna talk about
how this credit crunch
could be worrying some folks
about the likelihood of
recession and we're gonna talk
about just some of the
data that we're going to
get that's gonna tell us
about banks pulling back
on some lending and some
other important pieces there.
Second, we are gonna get some data
on the health of the consumer.
I've got a big report coming out
that I've been telling you guys
to watch out for for months.
Each month that it's come in
it has been a little bit more worrisome.
We're gonna get the latest
update on that later this week.
And third of course, jobs.
We have four, count 'em,
four big reports coming out this week
on the US labor market that
are gonna tell us a lot
of very important things.
So these are the three
things that you need to
be watching out for this week.
We are gonna get into all of them,
what they are and what
they mean right now.
So let's first start off
with the state of business.
So there are some worries that
US lending is going to slow
because of bank run fears, right?
These fears of what happened
with Silicon Valley Bank,
Signature Bank, Credit
Suisse, Deutsche Bank.
We've seen it really
reverberate around the world.
Wanna throw something
up here on your screen
to just kind of illustrate what a lot
of people have been worried about.
Now, what you're seeing right now
is the Fed's senior loan
officer opinion survey
and this just is basically
the percentage of
banks that say they're tightening
their lending standards.
What that means is they're
making it harder to give
out loans requiring more from people.
Maybe it's higher credit scores,
maybe it's more collateral.
Basically just saying we're
making it a bit tougher
because we're worried
about lending money out.
Now that number you see there
at the edge of your screen,
the latest number where
we are, that's about 45%
of banks saying they are
tightening lending standards,
making it harder to give out loans.
We are already in the area
which typically historically,
if you look on your screen there
you see all those little shaded
areas that note recession.
Every time we get to the level
that we are at right now,
level that we were at in January,
this isn't even where we are right now.
This is before this banking crisis issue.
We have had a recession.
So that's why this survey
is very informative.
It tells you about
historical trends we have
seen going back all the way 30 years.
The study started in the
1990s and as you see,
when we get to the levels
that we're at right now,
there has been a recession
every single time.
So wanted to just put
that on your screen to
illustrate the historical
trend of this survey
and why it's been a fairly
accurate predictor of recessions.
Now here's the data that we get this week
because that survey the update
to that doesn't come out until May.
We are going to get, this morning,
we already got the US manufacturing PMI.
That actually was up
from the previous month, still below 50.
So still showing a contraction,
but moving in the right direction.
There have been some worries
about US manufacturing.
A lot of surveys on
manufacturing have been just
in the gutter for quite some time.
Global manufacturing has
showed that it's picked up.
We will get another report
on the global manufacturing
PMI this morning
in just about an hour at
11:00 AM Eastern time.
And we also get the reports
on services, US Services PMI
and Global Services PMI,
that's Wednesday and Thursday.
PMI surveys, Purchasing Managers Indexes,
basically are where these companies go out
and they say to businesses,
"Hey, how are you doing?
"Are you ordering more?
Are you ordering less?
"Are you hiring more, hiring less?
"Are things costing more, costing less?"
And then they put together
a sentiment index.
50, anything above 50 mean
things are going well,
they're improving, anything below 50
means they're getting worse.
We will get a bunch of
those out this week.
And in fact we just got one this morning,
came in just below 50
for the US manufacturing sector showing
that things are still
getting a little bit worse,
but improving from where they were.
Also on Tuesday we get factory orders,
which is exactly what it sounds like,
what factories are ordering.
Then we get US trade balance,
the US Trade Balance Report
that comes out on Wednesday.
Last month we saw that orders declined
because there were less
imports, also less exports.
So the the US trade balance
decreased, but it was just
because there was less overall
business being conducted,
not necessarily what you want.
A big thing coming up this week,
the IMFs spring meetings,
the International Monetary Fund,
they're having their
financial stability report
released Wednesday and
IMF managing director,
Kristalina Georgieva
will be having her press
conference kicking off
the spring meetings.
That's on Thursday.
If you want to know about the state
of global business,
business around the globe,
you're gonna want to tune into those
on Wednesday and Thursday.
And finally,
on Thursday we get the Fed's
discount window borrowing
for the previous week.
We have seen the Fed pushing out billions,
hundreds of billions of dollars back
into these banks to help sturdy them up.
We are going to get the
latest update on that.
The Fed has been trying to
reduce its balance sheet,
trying to tighten up the economy
through its quantitative tightening.
Well they're doing that at the same time
as they're pushing a bunch of money back
out into the economy.
We'll get the latest
report on that on Thursday.
Now the second thing, the
state of the consumer.
We have seen that consumers
are loading up on debt.
We will get the latest report
on consumer credit on Friday.
That's gonna be big.
It's gonna give us the February numbers.
Now here's why that matters.
We did a report or a video
on this a month or two
ago called, what is it?
Credit card debt, or I'm sorry,
it's credit card debt is hitting,
credit card delinquencies,
excuse me, are skyrocketing.
Now, that video came out about a month ago
we're gonna link to it on the page
on the VOD so you can watch it there.
But we are seeing increased
defaults by businesses.
We're seeing increased
delinquency rates by individuals.
Basically people are
taking on a bunch of debt
and a bunch of credit
that they can't afford
and they're starting to go delinquent.
Same thing is happening with businesses.
We're not reaching levels
that are worrisome yet.
It's still a small number of people
but the increase has been very rapid.
One of the fastest
increase rates in history.
We break all that down in the video
so make sure you check that out.
Now the third big theme this week, jobs,
J-O-B-S, jobs, jobs, jobs.
And it's all about jobs,
not just about the state
of the economy, but for what's
gonna go on with inflation.
And a big thing, a big piece
of that inflation puzzle
has been the JOLTS report.
We will get the latest
update on that Tuesday.
Want to throw something
up here on your screen
to kind of show you what
I'm talking about with jobs.
Now what you're seeing there
is the number of job openings
in the JOLTS survey and the
number of unemployed people.
And as you can see, the
number of job openings
historically had never risen
above the number of unemployed people.
We are seeing that now where it's not only
are there more job openings
than there are unemployed people,
there's about two to one,
there's about two openings
for every unemployed person,
that hasn't moved yet.
You see there at the edge of your screen,
that number not really going
higher, not really going lower.
They're staying about stagnant.
Fed chair, Jerome Powell has
highlighted this and said,
"Hey, this is a problem for the economy.
"It's giving workers a
little too much leverage,
"giving them more leverage
to negotiate higher raises,
"higher pay increases
when they start a new job.
"And that's gonna keep inflation high."
The Fed needs to bring
inflation back down.
Basically the problem
is consumers have money
and when they have money,
they go out and spend.
And so even when companies
are raising prices,
increasing prices over and
over, consumers keep paying
and that's what pushes inflation higher.
So Fed has been watching
this, you should watch it.
JOLTS report out on Tuesday.
This charge is kind of
illustrating the overall theme
that we've seen with job
openings and unemployed people.
That's big.
We also get the ADP report from March,
that's out on Wednesday.
And then we get also on Thursday
the Challenger Job Cuts report.
Wanna throw this up on your screen
really quickly to illustrate
the theme that we've seen through the
Challenger Job Cuts.
Now you see low, low, low, low,
low levels of cuts, those are layoffs.
And then boom, you see a
pickup there towards the end.
We saw in the March report a 410% increase
over the year before.
In February we saw a 440%
increase over the year before.
So big pickups in the Challenger Job Cuts.
And that just kind of
illustrates the overall theme
of layoffs.
We are starting to see a pickup
in layoffs and of course
last but certainly not least
we get the Non-Farm Payrolls
Report from the government
US Labor Department
putting that out on Friday.
We will be right here on market takes.
So be here with us, and you know what?
Get your fill.
We'll be talking about
what the markets are doing,
how the markets are responding,
and get you caught up
on everything that you
need to know for that day.
So listen, that's gonna do it
for us here on Market Takes.
Like I said, I know you
could have been anywhere
in the world, could have been
knocking at the door next door
with those people, but you
were right here with me
on Market Takes and I hope
you'll be with us on Friday.
We'll see you then on Market Takes.